I think people underestimate how hard it is to untangle ourselves...
...from a social network like Facebook.
So, before you delete your Facebook account,...
...just remember that it's not just Facebook that you'll be losing access to.
It's also all of the third-party apps that you use Facebook to log in to...
...or that are connected or plugged into your Facebook account.
So, it's important before you make this choice to go through those apps,...
...see which ones you still need access to,...
...and if there are any, to switch your login from Facebook to something else...
...so you can still access it even after you've deleted your Facebook account.
And there are just some apps that you won't have access to...
...if you delete your Facebook account.
Facebook has a lot of ways to track your activity even if you're not logged in...
...or if you delete your account entirely,...
...and it uses what it calls the social graph...
...to track the activity of people across the internet beyond just Facebook.com.
This accounts for everyone who uses the internet,...
...and you don't have to have a Facebook profile to be tracked by Facebook.
For example, if your friends have Facebook accounts or Facebook Messenger accounts...
...and if they've uploaded their contacts to Facebook...
...and if you're one of their contacts,...
...then Facebook knows your name and your phone number and can track you.